okay let's get into the fun can you tell
me what is plasma the simple explanation
would be like the plasma it is what we
have in fluorescent lamps if you look
around in your home it is something you
have in all kind of sources like a most
of monitors TV screens etc significant
number of them let's plays most plasma
plasma is ionized gas what does it mean
like we have gas around us and let's say
with electric field electrons are
separated from ions so yes you take
electron out of molecule so molecule
becomes positive ion and electron is
separate with an iron iron it's a if you
take if you take an atom or molecule and
take one electron out would stay there
so iron it is like a atom or molecule
after the saraburi when they lost an
electron and what's interesting about an
ion okay very second probably when you
apply electric field whoever is lighter
take energy immediately energized very
fast so I ins they stay regularly
usually they stay cold because they are
heavy they are not very much moving so
they are stay cold while electrons are
energized almost immediately yeah and
their temperature in most of plasmas
whatever you do electron temperature is
usually on ballpark it's about ten
fifteen thousand Kelvin or Celsius which
means twenty thirty thousand Fahrenheit
ha so electrons are very very very very
very hot and ions like gas they're
usually in most cases they're cold so if
I take like a cell phone and touch the
screen well inside you have where you
often have electrons with the
temperature the phone is 30,000
Fahrenheit but you cannot feel it why
because it's a one electron per million
of molecules it's not so many of them
it's like let's say Syria Philadelphia
do we have billionaires in the city of
Philadelphia maybe 100 but it's but it's
not so much easy to meet them on the
street because it's only one or two for
a huge city so the same story here so
plasma it is very energized electrons
and usually relatively cold gas but
these electrons they can do a lot like
these billionaires in Philadelphia few
have like a couple of these billionaires
they can do a lot it's only two of them
but actually they can influence life in
the city more than ever cells because
they have abilities the same story there
so electrons depending on gas they are
able to create very active species so
they can be used as a source of light
like a fluorescent lamps and they can be
used to three different materials so
most of synthetic well I would say 100%
of synthetic materials they are treated
before coloring because like you have a
nice black tie but how to make tag black
if it is synthetic if it is natural is
solid real but if it is synthetic
material and if you try you know paint
synthetic material you know pain does
not stick to it
so you plasma treated this electron to
activate the surface and colors they
start sticking to the surface what is me
to activate the surface so there's a lot
of plasma is interacting somehow with
the surface well there's human skin or
some kind of surface so what does it
mean to treat a surface okay it's right
it's dead with more division but it's
you know if you have polymer like in the
case of your thigh if I would like a
polymer what what this electron does is
just create or H and this for H take
hydrogen out of your tie and this is a
opening bond and usually oxygen stick to
there and become polar so you cover the
surface with a polar groups which are
always sticky so that's what is going on
you just take one atom out you have free
bound oxygen there polar groups you
stick you can paint if if you put a
droplet droplet of whiskey on the surfer
of glass it will stay like a droplet but
if you just plasma treat this glass and
then you put drop the droplet loops
immediately cover very significant area
okay so let's let's step back a little
bit so there is solid liquid gas you
said yeah it's ionized gas why is plasma
sometimes called the fourth state of
matter mm-hmm so what's the difference
between gas and ionized gas mm-hmm
such that it's a fundamental difference
it is the fundamental difference because
like what is going on that this ionized
gas immediately has very different
behavior the word plasma was actually
created just because of similarity with
blood plasma
so like you ask the difference between
plasma and gas it is about the same
difference
like difference between the water and
blood so species inside the blood
they're very much interacting with each
other while water they're not much
interacting so why here wing length
mirror in 1934 36 he started using the
word class my versus ionized gas because
he said take a look take a look take a
look this species they interact with
each other and I didn't know that so
there's there's a close connections to
inspiration from blood plasma yes and
the thickness of the interactivity more
than that so the the guy who just Nobel
Prize laureate earring Wrangler was at
first for analyzed by the interaction
plasma search on the surface so you can
say that he's like a father of modern
electronics hardware so he come up with
this work
take a look this plasma is kind of funny
it looks like a blood plasma and people
they start like using this phrase like a
joke then you know like everybody like
it stuck
oh that's really interesting okay so you
said electrons really hot so
so traditionally plasma is supposed to
be very high-energy very hot so he said
train its electrons but there's a hot
plasma and cold plasma so we'll two four
four okay in hot plasma everything is
hot so if you have more electrons and
they are able to heat up the whole gas
it's a hot plasma like solar plasma the
Sun Sun solar plasma Sun and in this
case temperature is very high fusion
plasma so just everything is very hot
in most of engineering plasmas today
including your cell phones including
fluorescent lamps etc or in these case
only electrons are their huts and they
are unable to heat up everybody it's
like this couple of billionaires in the
city of middle-class people and but
these electrons there if it is air for
example they just electrons they react
with oxygen making atomic oxygen atomic
oxygen immediately produce ozone so
atomic oxygen sticks to all - creating
also by the way ozone means I think in
Latin means smell so the name of the guy
who first saw that it was Siemens
if you remember company Siemens so
that's the creator of this company
because he was the first one to
understand this ozone and said well how
it smells
then he they used like a legend or third
word for that it was on and they start
using ozone for water cleaning right so
what's hot plasma and what's cold plasma
so you said in the cold plasma the
electron like the billionaire's is the
only thing that stays hot so what hot
plasma everybody be on earth and so in
terms of applications in terms of the
theoretical physics under underpinning
what's the difference between hot plasma
and cold plasma there's entire groups of
researchers that work on that yes yes
you know the fundamental difference is
when everything is 10,000 degrees what
we can do with this material with this
plasma it's like everything is ten
thousand like a ten thousand Kelvin like
a twenty thousand Fahrenheit what you
can do I mean that stuff melts
everything and convert everything into
vapor when so scientifically it's very
easier because it's like as
close the thermodynamic equilibrium so
just very very very hot substance one is
elementary applications applications the
major application is if you wanna melt
something which require temperature
above yeah
2,000 Celsius which is what the Isis
torches so if you want the he as you
want a hot metal metal you can actually
you can cut metal with most of metals
they're just you know they melt it on
the level of below 2000 so for these
metals with some exceptions but for
these metals fire you know
combustion torches there okay now if you
wanna melt something which is impossible
to melt like a special hard ceramics
if you cannot melt it with anything
first of all why do you need it why do
you need melt something which is
impossible to Makaha if you let's say if
you want to protect your airplane your
airplane it's a good idea to cover
airplane with this thin layer of a
substance which is impossible to to melt
which is not afraid of anything not
afraid of lightning I'm not afraid of
anything how to do that
you have to melt we have to cover it
with this material but to cover we have
to melt it now how to melt something
which is impossible to weld
well you have to take plasma so plasma
goes hot flat thermal plasma goes to
this huge temperature then you put this
powder you melt it and you spray what's
thermal plasma that's the heart kind of
that's a high temperature plasma
okay so what's cold plasma then and what
kind of temperatures are we talking
about what's this world in terms of
applications and theory thence now
fundamentally different from the hot air
kind ah cold plasma it is in its
situation when you have electrons only
electrons are hot and they generate a
lot of active species radicals atoms so
they can treat different materials they
can make
very sophisticated structures but
temperature is low so you do not damage
so let's say jumping toward special
intelligence if you are talking about
computer how to make computer how to
make this wafers how to make these chips
yeah you have to be able to dig tiny
tiny tiny tiny tiny ditches how to do
that
you have to have you cannot use
mechanical devices so you have to have
something different beams lasers no
because laser is heating its temperature
but you cannot take if you just use
laser you go to temperature eight or
nine thousand degrees you'll damage your
phone cannot withstand this temperature
yes the same computer so that's why
there is no alternative today only cold
plasma to make I would say vast majority
of electronics devices so hardware it's
almost you say hardware it is that so
let me beautifully put what's now you
said application we'll talk about some
applications including plasma medicine
but from a if we if you put on your
theoretical physicist or chemist like
fundamental science higher what are the
interesting problems in plasma the
mysteries they're not yet understood or
things that have been recently
understood I've seen you talk about
incredible applications but let's step
let's not cover that first is there some
open problems how was it understood from
a theoretical perspective I can give you
a couple of examples it's a lot of
mysteries a lot why because this is
strongly non equilibrium medium almost
every cells which we have around us it's
an equilibrium what was I mean what does
it mean for a medium to be an
equilibrium equilibrium units has
temperature
has temperature yeah some temperature
like this is let say room temperature
well no I mean what you mean by that is
there's a uniformity to it uniformity in
temperature not space uniformity but
homogeneity like it's yeah if
temperature now can you imagine
something which has a couple of
different temperatures at the same point
as it possible yeah that's what it is so
electrons are very hot but they are
inside of gas and gas is cold like like
people they're swimming in the ocean so
temperature of a person is higher but
he'll just temperatures way way way
higher
now what starts happening in this case
it's a lot of funny miracles a lot of
funny miracles for example electron
impact creates excitation of molecules
to Marco's a stylus oscillate and people
will learn that distribution this
becomes very strange energy rich
molecules they they take more energy
when they have already something and
okay rich people they become richer and
poor people then becomes more poor
exactly the same thing they call it
capitalism in molecular life happens in
plasma so what is going on
you take molecules in plasma excite and
very fast against all the rules of
whatever nature couple of molecules they
have to quantum and they have more and
more and more and more than normal and
very soon like some molecules they have
everything and most of molecules have
nothing as a result you have this kind
of non equilibrium immediately creates
lasers so this is one of the reason why
lasers first of--first lasers they were
created in plasma even now the most
energetic like co2 laser is a plasma
lasers and
is also plasma laser so that has mice
very accelerated application but physics
is here I can explain it a little bit
longer how it works but it's very
similar to what is going on with people
if you already have money it's easier
for you to attract new money if you are
actually poor sooner or later you will
lose your money in the favor of rich
people not sure how well that analogy
works but probably but they're saying
that there's some fascinating
complicated instability about that hole
but it's interesting it's interesting
instability its instability not space
instability its energy instability yeah
it's like a yes you said capitalism
capitalism at the molecular level it's a
it's a capitalism it's a like a wild
capitalism yeah where just everything
works against middle class who's the
Bernie Sanders in this physics analogy
I'm just kidding that's a who's the
social oh okay I don't know let's not
take this analogy that's interesting
that you know that plasma works works
against Bernie Sanders so nature nature
yeah
nature's as a more Republican isn't more
of a public nature is Republican well no
not nature and in plasma Nanakuli it's
only non equilibrium flat
non-equilibrium plasma equilibrium
plasma it's everything it's very much
Bernie Sanders it's very much harness
distribution
yeah well non-equilibrium plasmas let's
live a short life and die quickly so yes
so if you want a long peaceful existence
you want to go that's one of the reasons
why will this Bernie Sanders visit
that's very interesting that but for
this reason non-equilibrium plasma cold
plasma is able to produce way more
miracles as miracles meaning very
interesting strange siren rapturous
patterns
treatment like you cannot use hot plasma
to make electronic device well you can
do it it's just one example another
example is like a recently I came
yesterday well yeah yesterday from Japan
so we presented
ionization of liquids not guesses so
it's a lot of interesting new stuff Oh
liquids very interesting yeah so you've
mentioned physics in chemistry what is
plasma physics and what is plasma
chemistry in terms of application in
terms of theory what are the different
lenses of physics and chemistry that you
used to explore plasma and how do they
differ you have books on each yes
the simplest I think that it was fine
one who was asked what is physics and I
think it's him
and after some thinking he said well
that's what physicists do yeah so that's
a good point so actually it's a nice way
to say that's a stupid question but it
gives the question of more of a chance
so what's the difference between plasma
physics plasma chemistry in even physics
and chemistry more broadly in can I mean
I don't know what's the more easier
distinction to draw yeah I can compare
with languages like what's the
difference between English language and
Chinese language in one case you have
how many I forgot 23 or whatever
characters how many well yeah it
survived okay something something 20s
yeah and in Japanese oh and the Chinese
you have ten thousand forty thousand
characters so Chinese it's chemistry
English it's physics
has small number of rules and laws of
nature and operates with that so
understanding let's say how to ionize
gas it's physics understanding how to
create plasma in liquid it's physics
understanding how to make a device how
to make a light source
plasma light source it's physics now
when we are coming to Chinese I line
into this earth chemistry it means that
there is a million different tables not
rules tables yes it's tables instead of
rules and so what's not going on you
just look at that and see oh my gosh
this glass my special and on equilibrium
plasma creates thousands of species and
we have to understand what kind of
species and sometimes you need these
species but you don't need these species
so how to have more of that and how
would I have less of these and there is
no rules well there are some rules but
about as much as in create creating
Chinese characters so a lot of it is a
lot of the knowledge in plasma chemistry
is discovered through experimentation
yeah and I would say chemistry is more
art physics is a little bit more science
like linguistics you know English
language it's possible that's also a lot
of challenges but it's simple well
talking about simple and complicated
going from physics to chemistry let's go
to biology one of the exciting feels
that you're one of the founders of is
plasma medicine yeah what is plasma
medicine ok cold plasma cold plasma
creates a lot of species interesting
species unexpected species you remember
this capitalism in molecular life you
can a little bit change parameters and
it can be wrong
look I start generating this strange
substance etcetera so plasma is very
sensitive the difference it's like a
human body and asthma generates very
interesting active species actually to
be honest almost exactly the same so
professor David Gray's he keeps saying
that he was impressed when he looked you
know books of medical biology books and
he said like a species active species
inside of human body and in Copeland
they're the same so plasma create is
very interesting stuff and it was clear
for people from the beginning like
already for more than hundred years that
if you put plasma in contact with human
body
you can treat some diseases you can do a
lot of stuff the problem was that if
plasma is energetic and you put this
energetic plasma in contact with human
body you kill the person so actually the
whole point the whole interesting point
of plasma medicine so plasma medicine
came from physicists actually where it
become possible to make uniform not
damaging very energetic plasmas example
at atmospheric pressure example we have
atmospheric pressure around atmosphere
and there is a lightning lightning is
hot and very energetic and very damaging
plasma sources plasma discharges like
lightning it's impossible to use to
treat human body you'll just throw a lot
of this trial why do you kill the
competition yeah now what happened like
when 16 years ago it was the first time
when this is to learn how to make
lightning not like a concentrated in a
tiny channel to be diffused and just
around a big big big big area like to
make it something like a aurora borealis
from lightning and it was actually in
1990s a lot of like efforts it was a
French approach they just etc but
finally we won because what we it was
like a out-of-the-box solution to make
extremely short electric pulses short
especially or temporal in time time in
time so let's say because we have when
we have lightning between clouds and
ground
it's like a continuous voltage but if we
apply this voltage between skies and
ground let's say a couple of nanoseconds
there is no time to create the Lightning
Channel just simply no time so what is
going on you start creating something
like aurora borealis so you have a
glowing everywhere because there is no
time to create a channel so you make
this pulse and then you stop yes and
then you repeat this pulse again then
you stop and you repeat this pulse again
so through this not a second passing it
is impossible to create a uniform class
and if plasma is uniform it's not
damaging aurora borealis you will not
kill anybody with lightning you will so
that allows you not damaging to now
start allowing plasma to interact with
the human body somehow so treating
tissues for example yes why is that
interesting what yeah what kind of
applications are we talking about okay
today the biggest application is related
to treatment of chronic wounds like
officers especially diabetic ulcers also
recently treatment of cancers because
our plasma sources are permitted to be
used during surgeries so when like a
surgeon is making a surgery he removes
cancer but some margins are not treated
so they start using this plasma just to
remove tissue bad tissue without damage
because it is instead of like a scalpel
it's like a jet small jet
for wounds it's a very effective
generation of the stimulation of
angiogenesis so just drawing on blood
vessels so that I would say two most
successful applications today what
plasma related Nobel Prizes do you think
will be given in the next fifty years so
if you look at at the big ideas and
plasma what do you think is there to be
discovered understood or may have
already been understood and and will be
recognized for it okay closer to our
field at least where we are playing and
if we are fielders first I would say
cold plasma for magical biological
applications I would say if there is a
significant actually accepted by FDA etc
success and treatment of cancer there is
a big chance to get Nobel Prize what
discipline would you get it will be
medicine in medicine that's fascinating
that's fascinating that is this another
example which I like a lot personally it
is this plasma ionization of liquids
without bubbles that's the chance also
to get Nobel Prize for that because its
first of all it's a fascinating physics
ionization of liquids are bubbles what's
the niche of the bubbles that form if
you take liquid and put like a two
electrodes in the liquid to ionize
liquid you need a huge electric field at
least that's what most people they used
to think because mean free path is small
so electrons they they have to be
accelerated to have this huge energy so
it's either electric field is huge
or there is enough distance just ruth to
accelerate now you have liquid that's no
much place to to go
so you have to have about a thousand
times greater electric field or you have
to create some voids if you create voids
and scent of liquor that's okay now
that's what people that you still
believe but maybe about five seven years
ago people they understood that even
when they have very high electric field
but not a huge and they start having
ionization of liquids so just the same
as plasma in fluorescent lamps but you
have the same thing in liquid and first
was very interesting physics it's a
longer story to explain it's very
interesting physics but also it's very
interesting location because you have
possibility to have cold plasma inside
of liquid so you can synthesize new
materials you can do something so that
was the reason like I came a couple of
history making this presentation of
these discharges and creation of this in
the discharge creation of polymeric
nitrogen because people they don't have
nitrogen polymers today and that's in
cold plasma it was synthesized so it is
very interesting from fundamental point
of the field synthetic chemistry but
nobody were able to make like this kind
of chain from nitrogen right so that was
created it's very interesting now this
material at normal conditions is
converted back to regular nitrogen
releasing huge energy way more than any
explosive materials so okay so those are
two interesting ideas yeah close close
to your heart what about what about the
Sun what about hot thermal plasma do you
think there's an interesting open
problems there that will help us
understand the universe or something
like that I don't think so
today there is no I think for for
thermal plasma there is very low chances
for Nobel Prize kind of results however
there is a so-called fusion plasmas so
plasmas
because the thermal plasma which we
discuss it's the thermal engineering
plasmas it's it's plasmas like melting
welding these kind of applications
coatings and surface of the Sun surface
of the Sun but if you go to higher
temperatures you have fuel nuclear
fusion but if in normal plasma thermal
plasma temperature is about ten thousand
Kelvin ten thousand for fusion you have
to have 100 million - it's more Wow so
inside the Sun it's a deeply inside and
the physics there is interesting physics
is extremely interesting because it's a
lot of questions with stability and this
plasma this kind of temperature will
behave very different so it is it is I
would say super fluidic material
you